on the tenth day of Christmas we have to
really quite unusual elements which you
might not have seen before
we have opium which is one of the few
metals that's blue and this is a very
beautiful crystalline example if you
look it's sparkles as you move your head
osmium is one of the densest metals it
has arguably the highest melting point
there's some argument whether it's
iridium or osmium they're very close
together and they're both very high the
other element is the hardest one to get
hold of of any element up to uranium and
this is thorium which is element number
19 so this was a present from Max Whitby
and Thea Grey who are specialists in
preparing samples of the elements
thorium is particularly hard to
transport you can't send it through the
post because it's radioactive so they
gave it to me and I brought it back to
Nottingham in my pocket I was slightly
worried that there might be
anti-terrorist radiation meters but I
think the plastic is sufficiently thick
that you can't get any radiation out
from it
we'll be making a video quite soon about
thorium but it's quite interesting the
sample here are more wires than the lump
and it's a slight blackish color which
quite surprised me the osmium was a
present from a fan I was at a conference
and he jumped up from the audience as I
was walking through and said I have a
present for you and whipped out some
osmium from his pocket I was amazed for
day ten we have two really exciting
elements osmium thorium
day nine periodic table handkerchief a
child piece of wood seven a fan from a
fan six element carbon five a glowing
plectrum for drinking vessels three
chemical badges two periodic table bed
covers and one piece of tartaric acid
from a Swiss wine barrel let's see what
we get for day 11
Plus this one pair of stars in tight
orbit around one another the Sun then
encountered this binary star one of the
things we know about those follicle
three-body encounter so binary star as a
first community is that the first off
can get kicked out of high speed and in
fact the typical speed you'd expect the
Sun to get kicked out out in that case
is around 20 kilometers per second
you